the thing I wanted to talk about today
one of the things is the coolness that
is public private key cryptography the
basic idea of how it works I think is
it's just cool that's such a clever idea
that I wanted to explain it so
everyone's familiar with the basic idea
of crypto where you you have a secret
key
you use that to encode some information
which converts it from a readable form
into garbage effectively it's rat looks
like random noise you then transfer that
to somebody else and they are then able
to decrypt it and get the message out
and anyone who's listening in on your
communication isn't able to find out
anything about the information that
you're communicating the way that you
intuitively think about it especially if
you're doing the simple code something
like a Caesar cipher that you might do
when you're a kid there's one there's
one secret that you both have right this
is this is a symmetric system so you've
got your message you're saying hello and
then you do some process to it to
convert it using a key that's some
secret piece of information which then
converts this into nonsense and then you
send this to the other person and they
decrypt it with a process that's kind of
this same process in Reverse using the
same key and then they get hello back
out the other end and that's nice and
simple it works and it was once sort of
the only way that people did things but
it has a problem which is you both need
to know what this key is so if it's you
and me and we want to communicate with
one another privately we have to agree
on a key that nobody else is going to be
able to guess and we have to share it
with one another so we might meet in the
park in secret and exchange envelopes or
whatever this is the kind of thing spies
used to do right and the problem with
that is firstly it's very inconvenient
and secondly sometimes you can't do it
like we might be physically separated we
all we want to do something over the
internet maybe we've never met and the
problem is how do I send this key to you
without just sending the key in the
clear as it were
encrypted in order for us to share the
key safely we need a secure encrypted
connection but we can't establish a
secure encrypted connection without a
key there's a way of solving this
problem which is asymmetric encryption
where what you do is you generate two
keys key a and key B let's just call
them I'm gonna draw a line here
asymmetric system you have two keys and
then basically it's the same as before
you've got your message that says hello
you encrypt it with key a to say
whatever it was that I decided it was
before and then back out you get hello
again and the decryption in this case
uses key B you can't guess one key from
the other but they're linked in such a
way that anything you encrypt with key a
can only being decrypted with key B and
anything you encrypt with key B can only
be decrypted with key a so there's two
and what you do is you generate a pair
of these keys which is called a key pair
and you just pick one of them and say
this is my public key right and your
public key is public you publish it
everywhere you put it you know you put
it on the end of all your emails your
forum posts you upload it to a key
server just a specialized server system
that's designed for storing securely
storing people's people's public keys
basically the idea is it's everywhere
out there in the world with your name on
it the private key is the other key of
this pair that one you keep absolutely
secret if you can do some cool things
with this once you have this system set
up I have a key pair you have a key pair
we both have one another's public keys
so now if you want to send me a message
I don't have to share anything with you
you just know my public key encrypt
something with my public key send it to
me you know I can decrypt it because you
know I have my private key and then
there's another thing you can do with
this which is if I encrypt something
with my private key and then publish it
now on the surface of it you think well
what is the point of encrypting it with
your private key because your public key
is out there so anyone can decrypt it so
why bother encrypting it but the fact
that can be decrypted with your public
key means that it must have been
encrypted with your private key
which means it must have been you who
made the message because only you have
your private key cryptographically you
can be certain that it's an authentic
message really from that person so the
best thing is when they do both where I
encrypt something with my private key
and then your public key and then send
it to you and if we communicate like
this I know that nobody else can read
the message you know that nobody else
can read the message you know that the
message has come from me and not an
imposter you also know that the message
hasn't been modified because any
modification to the message also
requires the keys that's a great secure
system and we didn't have to meet up in
the park in a shifty way and exchange
any information or anything we need
never have met I need to make clear here
that I have oversimplified in various
ways people who understand cryptography
will be quite upset
probably right now but guys this is this
is why people don't use crypto because
we make it too complicated the core
concept is simple and the basic that if
this stuff isn't difficult to use and
everyone should when you put an envelope
in the post you know you kind of assume
you lick the thing and seal it and if
it's been opened people know it's been
opened and there are laws about this and
we have a look at stuff and when you
communicate in the clear you know anyone
and his dog can know exactly what you're
sending to everyone and there's no
reason to allow that
ways in which what I've done here is is
a simplification and there are some ways
in which it's an oversimplification and
if you want more details just look down
in my trousers where there's a lot of
commenters who will have gone into extra
quad you don't need to actually zoom in
on it I mean there's a lot of commenters
who will have gone into more detail than
you wanted about exactly how this stuff
works and it is really interesting but
the basic idea is simple